the perfect European Escape over the
holidays travel zoo senior editor Gabe
sagley takes us to Northern Ireland
where cities like Belfast and dairy
offer American Travelers great food and
activities and a lot of seasonal fun
hey there guys I'm here with Ian
mcelhenney who was of course barriston
the Bold uh in four of the first five
seasons of Game of Thrones we're
enjoying the brand new Game of Thrones
Studio Tour here in bambridge in
Northern Ireland but also a chance in to
talk about something great traveling
opportunities around your home Northern
uh Ireland in fact we got to hang out in
beautiful downtown Belfast just the
other day where the Christmas markets
are in full swing people love to come
here in the summer but Ian a great time
to visit would be the winter would be
the spring I mean you know at this time
of year okay it can be cold but very
often we get uh fantastic
shafts of sunlight you know because the
sun is low in the sky you get beautiful
fresh days you know and this country so
I can look very very beautiful in that
kind of weather you know and our
Countryside is stunningly lovely uh our
coastline is to die for our beaches are
you know are to die for I mean you get
on the beach at this time of year one of
the joys is you have it to yourselves
you know what I mean you're not having
to trip through loads and loads of
people you just get out there you get a
really brassy walk and you get stunning
views wherever you go so it's a great
place to to visit and to spend time in
the outdoors yeah Belfast was fantastic
to the West is the beautiful city of
Derry the walled city of dairy another
must do a lot of folks visit this city
during Halloween consider one of the
great Halloween destinations on the
planet but again uh the friendliness
that is pervasive across Northern
Ireland very evident in Dairy and the
eating would you say Ian that the
culinary reality here has really come uh
you know so far here just the last few
years yeah it's it's moved a pace and
you have a great variety a great uh
options across the whole International
menu really you know you can eat local
if you like you can also eat
International very easily
vegan and vegetarian is a common place
these days you know so from an eating
point of view there's great variety and
great opportunities you know and the
whiskey and now gin also becoming a very
big part of the culinary experience
seems to be the you go to of course but
then obviously if you're in Ireland you
have to drink starts to beard Guinness
or one of the other uh Brews but you
have to drink you you know start because
it's a very special drink you know and
we know the black stuff very special
here uh again uh you can find a Belfast
The Game of Thrones Studio Tour is about
30 minutes after that only about an hour
and a half north of Dublin if you fly
there so super accessible check out game
of thronesstudiotour.com check out
ireland.com and of course check out
travelzoo.com for all the deals that get
you out here Ian great to hang out with
you today back to you in Vegas